all right everyone thanks for dropping
to my talk today I'll be talking about
how you can win was simple and even some
linear models and as a reason why I'm a
little bit passionate about this because
if you are living on the internet or in
our sort of little filter bubble you may
have heard variants of this quote
something in a line of you should be
using deep learning and typically the
people who tell you this or people like
blogs reddit hacker news and some
YouTube stars and especially the latter
one is kind of weird because people are
rapping about variational Ottoman codes
and stuff and this got me thinking and
actually got me inspired to talk about
this because it's getting a little bit
worrisome and I love deep learning I
actually do it for clients but to be
very specific it feels more like people
are focusing about the tools they're
trying to apply then you know that
they're trying to actually solve a nice
problem and again like use deep learning
in production but I preferred the
simpler models and in this talk I hope
to convince you and I hope to explain to
you why it's not like deep learning
isn't amazing like it really is but
there's a bit of hype around it that's
distracting people from other great
ideas and some of those other ideas are
actually greater and you may be doing
yourself a bit short if you pay too much
attention to them now you can also win
with much simpler models that have
properties that are much nicer to have
in situations beyond that you put a
notebook and I'm an industry kind of
person I really care about what happens
in production so my goal is to learn you
back to the domain of boring old but
ultimately beautiful simple models I
hope we're excited about that in
particular there's a couple of topics
that I'll discuss and I will be going
over all these things relatively quickly
due to time and I hope that I will
mainly leave you with a lot of intuition
I'll start by saying that extraor
actually is a linear problem I'll show
you a lot of great time series tricks
especially if you're going to predict a
long time ahead I'll show you some small
feature engineering tricks will discuss
streaming models that's models that
learn data point per data point sort of
just on a large batch file I'm also
going to talk about recommenders a video
game recommender and afterwards I'll end
on something that I think might be the
future of machine learning I'm namely
hierarchical domain models so the XOR
problem you probably have a book on
neural networks and one of the main
arguments you typically hear on why you
should use a nonlinear model as opposed
to a linear one is that you cannot deal
with the XOR problem and it's a textbook
example and it's something like this so
let's say that our task is that we want
to click the blur
the new points and we want to separate
them from the red points and then people
say ah you need a nonlinear model for
that because there's no line that will
separate the classes so let's do an
experiment we put that into scikit-learn
so from scikit-learn import linear model
logistic regression this is a small
library that allows me to say the class
is dependent on the x1 and x2 thing in
this data frame I have my wide I've got
my X I took a little Jessica aggression
and yes the confusion matrix isn't great
and so then what people typically do is
they say ok let's use a model that's
easier to apply than to understand so
let's maybe use a support vector machine
and then you can see that the confusion
matrix is actually a lot better what I
could do though is I just look at this
data set sure right now of just these
two features I cannot separate them
linearly but how about I apply a small
trick what I'm gonna do is I'm just
going to say I'm going to add a third
column that are based on these two
columns so I'm going to say I'm going to
make a new column called x3 and it'll be
this number multiplied by that number
suddenly when I put that into this model
the computer matrix actually pretty damn
good so yes
XOR you can solve with a linear model
the trick here is that they just have to
do a small little feature engineering
trick and that was enough to already be
competing with this support vector
machine and I have a logistic regression
which is easy to explain and less stuff
goes wrong in production I can explain
it to this person in a suit that I'm
supposed to convince that machine
learning is great so already I'm seeing
lots of benefits by just you know adding
one line of code and this is this very
sort of textbook example I mean this is
just the demo of the linear method
solving a nonlinear problem but because
the linear model is applied in sort of a
nonlinear one we have much better
interpretability and there are many more
tricks that we can use and the main
reason for me as a consultant
especially if I'm either company who's
just starting out when I leave I
typically want my legacy to still be in
production I really like the idea that
suppose the company has great engineers
we're not maybe the best scientists I
can leave a linear model and I'm pretty
sure it's gonna work for the next two
years if it breaks they'll fix it
complex models don't have this property
sorry
the yeah well there's two types of
consultants left if you're interested in
this let's discuss business after shall
we
okay that was the first tackle well so
this is a very silly example of what I
hope to do now to show more of a
relevant example it's actually happening
quite often who here has a situation
where you want to predict your head like
if you're in retail or something like
that right this is something you
typically see and also here this is
nonlinear I've got something here that I
call X and this is definitely not a
linear relationship with X some things
about this data said it's fairly general
I think let's pretend it's daily data
we've got four years of it we want to
predict a year ahead maybe two it's a
fairly common piling task I hope you all
agree and I also hope you can smell from
here that the feature engineering will
play a large role and I'll just show you
one trick that I really really like and
then I hope we all agree that it's a
nice trick and that it will mainly work
in linear models what some people do is
they make dummy variable hint hint
dummy the word dumb isn't it what they
do is they say let's take like a
variable for a month in a year and
everything there will be averaged and we
kind of have a seasonal pattern and this
is true it's not the worst idea but I
mean the thing that I don't like about
it is I do want to be able to predict
from April 30th so let's say the data
that's in the next month and I do think
that points that are close to each other
should be able to influence one another
in dependence on whether or not there's
a separating line that decay the notes
if it's a new month so again we're gonna
do a feature engineering trick there's a
very complicated formula that's a shown
above but basically what I'm doing is
I've got some sort of hump that repeats
itself every year it's a radial basis
function that's another way we just call
it a hump there's a hybrid parameter
called alpha that allows you to make the
hump thinner or more thick but the nice
thing that I can do is I can make such a
hump for every January for every
February for every March and all the
other ones and the nice thing is when I
took this into a linear regression
there's something to be said you might
actually get a nice little smooth fit
over the data points are trying to
predict let's say a year ahead so what
you would typically do is you'd have
some sort of function in pandas that
generates these columns for you so this
is really a basis function for January
and then you know all the way up to
December let's pretend that this was the
data frame that we had and when we fit
this with a normal linear
that's it this is what comes out and
definitely compared to the dummy thing
that we were generating before this
looks a lot better it's a nice smooth
curve and again the only thing I did
hear was a nice little trick with
regenerating features and the cool thing
is I can actually go up to my manager
and I can say look I filtered out the
season there might be still some pattern
left but at least I've quantified what
the long-term season should be and all
of this just a couple of lines of extra
feature engineering and you know I'm
willing to argue that's actually a
pretty cool approach if you tune the
high parameter alpha they showed before
you get these sorts of things you still
want to do the normal feature
engineering and high parameter tuning
but we're actually still very flexible
in fact we're so flexible you can still
keep your contests happy because when
you put this into linear regression you
can still do all the stuff you're used
to doing with linear regression so if
you want to remove features that are
insignificant because we're still in the
linear domain we can actually remove
some features that aren't significant
for example which is also kind of cool
if you're into this thing I prefer other
methods but it's still kind of cool that
you can keep the frequentist friends
along yeah not too important another
thing I like about this and it just
deserves a mention real quick all the
magic can be explained but whenever I'm
at the client I don't know for sure if
they have so I could learn or if they've
got h2o or spark ml or positioning R or
Microsoft stuff but I'm pretty sure -
whatever stuff they have they have
linear regression so if I'm at least
able to use some of these feature
engineering tricks I'm pretty sure I'm
always able to find a way to get it to
production even if they have a different
stack than what I'm used to you can
implement this in Java or JavaScript
amazing and you can mold this feature
approach I mean right now I've generated
12 features but you can very well
imagine you might make 24 one for every
two weeks you can also imagine that you
have this feature for sort of the long
term thing in the year and you've got
another radial basis function for within
a certain width single day for example
and because everything is linear it's
relatively straightforward and I hope
you agree that's kind of a cool trick
what you can also do is you can have a
separate radial basis function for
different days of the week in the
Netherlands there's this weird thing
that on the Wednesday people typically
take the day off to be of the kids it's
the things the culture thing so maybe
the seasonal pattern is different for
Wednesdays that it is for Fridays so
what you can also do is just generate
such a season for every single day of
the week
and you can even extend this trick to
sort of generate a feature like this for
every single holiday for example if
you're buying Valentine's Day flowers
roses typically after a Valentine's Day
is done no one wants to buy roses
anymore so the price for roses just
drops and usually it's all the days
before Valentine's Day when the retail
prices go skyrocket so to accommodate
these sorts of effects that are kind of
like the season because they occur every
single year you can also make a feature
like this that depends on what
Valentine's Day happened you can still
get away with a lot of doing things and
just in your models and you can
interpret everything and you can still
tweak lots of stuff do that with your
neural network just and that's kind of
part of this part of the point I mean
you can still generate you can still
generate all these features and check
them into the neural network I mean
that's fine but it's not the point the
cleverness of what I just did came from
creativity but not focusing on the
algorithm per se but just start thinking
about the problem if you understand a
solution better than your problem you're
doing the you're doing it wrong I think
the note I mean a lot of people would
say maybe just chug it into some
gradient boosted the Machine or deep
neural network and I do hope that you
shouldn't expect that automatically
these features will be generated on your
behalf there's still something to be
said maybe not to the algorithm little
bit and think along I'll consider a
small variant to show that even now
we're still super flexible because
typically you don't have a season this
repeats itself every single time when
you typically have is something more
like this like there's some sort of
change in the season which season might
also change over time so oh my god
Kendall linear model still accommodate
this yes there's a couple of tricks that
you can do so normally in a linear model
you do this thing where you minimize the
error so this is the squared error that
you can minimize there's other people
that like to prefer to minimize
something else like the absolute error
it's also fine there are some other
people that say oh you can do this thing
called Ridge regression where you
basically punish it if the weights get
way too big which is actually a neat
trick and we can just write it down what
you can also do and that's actually what
I really like is you can also say well
you know what certain errors are more
important to me than other errors so if
stuff that happened five years ago I
care way less forward and stuff it
happened a month ago so we do the same
trick oh by the way if you do this you
can do this like a gradient descent
method but if you're a math nerd you can
also just write it down in the matrix
and there's a closed-form solution super
cool but you can also just do is you can
make another column in your train data
frame call that importance
and so I could learn you can use linear
models I think support vector machines
logistic regression also have support
for this it's pretty cool and what you
have to do beforehand is you have to go
to your pan assay the frame and
basically add some sort of importance
what I do here is I do some sort of
exponential decay all the way to the
back and I have another high parameter
for this stuff you can play with this is
what we had before this is what we have
now and you can see we really don't care
about the fit that happened in the past
much more but the thing that happens in
the future is fitting better even though
it's still not perfect this is a simple
circuit we can just go ahead and use
yeah so when you do this I'm going over
this very fast because I think I made
way too many slice than I have time for
but one thing that when you're doing
stuff like this what you typically can
want to do is you're going to end up
with a bunch of hyperparameters and at
least for me whoops
speaking of optimization better check
the cable but at least for me what I
really like there's these five lines of
scikit-learn and they work very well but
part of the stuff that I'm doing here is
in pandas and you cannot really put all
the pandas operations in these
scikit-learn pipe lines perfectly yet so
what I just do is I just make this one
function that have all the high
parameters as function inputs and then I
have some it's a library called evil
that I really like to play with it does
evolutionary algorithms and it's good
enough for my type of primary tuning in
general do whatever you will but keep it
simple that's the whole point another
thing that we could do just as another
trick this is a bit of syntax from our
in our this would be a way for me to say
hey I want to predict the variable Y and
it depends on all the other variables
what I can also do in arm is I can say
you know what I wanna have an
interaction term so don't just take the
radial basis function that I had before
but just multiplied by the time that way
the seasonal pattern might increase as
time increases because time increases
and it will multiply itself by that
feature and this is the R trick it
sounds like a DSL for model
specification but there's a cool library
in Python called Pasi that allows you to
take a string just like that and will
generate these features on your behalf
and it works on pandas dataframes it
automatically does won't have encoding
it's a pretty sweet library if I'm very
frank this is the first when I saw that
library that's when I started doing less
our machine learning it started moving
to Python it really helps when you run
this this is what the extrange like so
you still got the names of all the
variables that you make and you can see
that we still get all the original
variables that we're creating the only
thing that's been added is we also get
the time times the radial basis feature
etc it's pretty cool is it saves you a
lot of typing when you do this though
you're going to generate a whole lot of
features and then you should probably
wanna reduce them as well so things you
might want to consider is maybe just get
a rich model to prevent overfitting try
to remove variables in your high
performance search function because you
don't want to keep things small you can
apply t-test switched its stats models
you can also use whatever thing is
scikit-learn for feature selection that
you have but this is when we apply the
sample weights this is when we apply the
sample weights and add the interaction
terms so some parts are predicted better
if you just pay a bit of attention these
are two predictions a year ahead that
are somewhat reasonable but I can think
here it's predicting the end of the year
a little bit worse whereas here it was a
little bit better so it smells like
hyper parameters I think I described a
lot of texture basically that says
here's what I end up with and it's
pretty damn decent which is the main
point and all of this was done with the
simple models and a bunch of tricks and
I can still perfectly interpret the
model I can still play around with it
and here's a nice thing our example only
had three years of data so every year
for every single day there's only 1100
data points the radial basis functions
works in such a way that different
months can actually overlap in features
so I'm actually using as much
information as I can to generate all of
this and you know try doing this with a
deep neural network I don't know if you
need more than a thousand data points
you probably do something to be said at
least that you shouldn't expect a
recurrent neural network to
automatically solve all of this for you
but if I have let's say a thousand
different products I can generate all
these different radial basis functions
and just per product run this and I
should be able to filter out the season
still relatively nicely I I can sort of
there's two types of machine learning
models you got the Panda there's the
month you really want to care for that
model you want to optimize it perfectly
but in this case if I got a thousand
models I got a train I think this is
decent for general seasonal v linear
models are easy to maintain and the bug
something goes wrong we can inspect it
linear models
are actually kind of fast to train which
is also kind of nice I trained deep
learning in production now I have to
wait sometimes and they're also very
easy to explain to humans of Management
which especially if you're a consultant
live it's a very useful thing and here
comes my favorite reason and I didn't
expect this at all but when I'm running
a deep learning model in production
linear models are convex when the
optimizer says I'm done then I'm sure
it's done and it will not find a better
place in the training set for fit when
that when a neural network is done it
basically says well I don't I don't have
enough time to do anything more but it
can converge on something that's
completely bonkers and this is something
I have to worry about in production
besides all the other stuff I got to
worry about I now also have to check if
the convergence is OK is it something I
don't have a guarantee for anymore
tensorflow is a cool tool but it's even
cooler if you don't need it honestly if
you have ass I could learn algorithm
that's amazing but you can also just run
a sequel query the sequel curry is
better right the same thing goes for
tensor plug and again don't get me wrong
I put the various introductions and I
like the algorithms they solve problems
I couldn't solve otherwise especially in
text nowadays I'm seeing things that are
amazing but production is dangerous and
I don't want to wake up and that you
know 12 o'clock on a Sunday because
something went wrong I prefer to just
have paid or Doody off as well
so speaking of production I've just done
a lot of the linear models that are just
you know normal static files and we can
do some cool things with it but there's
some extra tricks that you can do and
especially if we're considering
production there's this whole realm of
machine learning that I haven't heard a
single talk on PI data yet so let's talk
about streaming because you know you
think about it instead of handling data
in a batch where we just have one giant
file you want to learn from maybe it
might be preferable to think about it in
a stream setting in production data will
probably come in in the stream we're not
going to usually you don't have someone
that says here's a CSV file please train
typically we get one data point at a
time and this is what we so kind of what
it looks like if you do it in bats what
you typically do is you train some sort
of function you learn it and then until
the next batch is sort of done with
training and event comes in and you
apply this one function and that's sort
of the prediction most machine learning
algorithm and the functions in the
source if you train which I could learn
something goes in something comes out
same thing goes in same thing goes out
but in this roaming situation we
would have it every day the point it
comes in might actually update the model
state and there's something be said
about being able to react quickly to the
world they're not having to wait for the
batch algorithm that's running on a
daily basis so there's an implementation
if I could learn it actually it sort of
does this but you can also imagine if
things like Apache flink or sparks
treating might have some implementations
that are interesting so I'll give you a
small explanation of how some of these
algorithms work this is a point that
lives in space and we're going to do a
regression on it and as far as this
point is concerned it doesn't care about
the blue line or the yellow line they
both have an equal fit they both go
straight to the point so these two lines
are somewhat equal as far as that one
point is concerned what I just said
however I can make a second plot what I
can do is this is again the point and
line going through and this is a plot of
x and y but next to it you see a plot of
the weight space so this is the
intercept and this is the slope and the
blue line core the blue dult here
corresponds with this blue line and the
yellow dots corresponds with the yellow
line as far as this point is concerned
every single thing on this straight line
is equal in terms of fit but now suppose
that I have some weights from like the
previous points that I've seen well then
I probably want to find like the
shortest distance from the original
weights that I had up until like that
plane well we have linear algebra for
that just put it on there with organelle
you're done and what we can also do is
well you know we want to move in that
direction but instead of overfitting how
about we take like a maximum step size
it seems like a good idea such as we
don't make sort of very aggressive moves
so this is sort of a bound there and the
idea then is as a stream comes in if my
whatever classification or regression
algorithm has a pretty good fit then I
maybe not update so let's only update
when we have giant errors when there are
giant errors that we were very
aggressive update this is called
passive-aggressive algorithms and I love
the name
and turns out that scikit-learn actually
has an algorithm linear regression and I
think also logistic regression for
passive-aggressive algorithms and I've
actually uses his client not so much for
the benefit of the streaming aspect but
more in terms of the benefit that you
also need a much smaller memory
footprint if you just have to handle
data one data point at a time there's no
longer a need to have the entire data
set in memory
say if you're only interested in sort of
preserving memory already this is an
interesting algorithm let alone sort of
the the actual streaming phenomenon
which is also very powerful so this very
small experiment because I still some
stuff that can go wrong that is constant
step size that can be big or small and
I'll just go over this very quickly you
can read the slides later what you can
do here you see what the fit is and here
you can see what the weights are doing
and if I in the beginning say let's in
the first 30 iterations take a somewhat
small step size and then also small
after you see that the fit is sort of
all over the place if I were to say oh
let's just take very small step sizes at
all times you see it takes a very long
time to even get near where it's
supposed to be but then you see that the
errors are much smaller typically what
you want to do is you want to be very
aggressive in the beginning that just
when the first 100 data points are so
that you see allow it to make huge steps
and then allow it to make only small
steps a thing that's also kind of cool
about these algorithms if this thing is
deployed and it's updating data point
per data point suppose now the world
changes a little bit
this thing will react this algorithm is
actually able to change its weights over
time but management says we should
implement tensor flow anyway this
approach can be on the live system and
especially useful when you've got labels
coming in it actually come in on the
stream it makes really if you have
real-time updating my weights it's very
sensible and if the world changes then
you can do some cool stuff extra details
or math are on the blog or in the
original paper that I prefer it here and
I'm immediately here you thinking dear
heckler like Vince that this is all
great but when do you actually have a
situation where a stream of data comes
in with a label because you know if you
have the label you don't need a
prediction right kind of true but let's
talk about recommender systems so the
nice thing about a recommender is when
someone clicks on the Internet then I
get a stream that comes in that says yes
this user click that thing so in this
case yes I have a label but I would
really like it if I'm able to use that
immediately to update some sort of
system when I'm in retail it's very
common for me that I don't see someone
for over half a year only for the person
to come back with completely new
preferences maybe half a year ago you
want to buy a Jaguar but now you've got
a care that you need diapers I would
really like to learn this in preferably
two mouse clicks I don't
for the batch algorithm to update and
here's the nice thing typically you have
a recommender system let's suppose did
you do collaborative filtering I think
it's fairly safe to say that the
features of an item don't change that
often over time but this features of
this user might and here's the cool
thing
this rating that we're trying to predict
via to click or an actual rating that's
a linear model if you're just doing
collaborative filtering and if you
assume that these items are actually set
you can do you specify ggressive
updating and suddenly you can do you can
still do bass right you can still do the
giant batch algorithm at night but then
during the day we now have a nice little
method to keep the model updated for
mouth click still a huge engineering
challenge but I'm no longer thinking
about you know accuracies and that kind
of thing I'm more thinking about how do
I want to make a cool system but
management wants us to use tensor flow
and this is a general thing I see go
wrong quite often especially when
companies are sort of starting with this
don't just think about machine learning
in general like think about machine
learning but maybe think more about
system design because you want to build
a system but you leave with the client
not so much just an algorithm algorithm
is thinking in just the notebook a
system is about actually making the
world better I just showed you
collaborative filtering we can do
something as a way simpler and way
better let's pretend that we're making
your Carender for the dutch BBC and just
the simplest idea that you could come up
with you can see you can probably
calculate the probability if you saw
this thing I call I and some sort of
duck show what is the probability is
you're going to see some other show so
what's the probability that you've seen
I and J together the problem with this
algorithm is that this can already be an
algorithm right but the problem with
this is everyone is probably gonna be
watching the news so no matter what you
watch I'm always gonna be recommending
you the news if I use this algorithm so
just you know as a mental counterbalance
just some sort of accounting how about I
divide this by the probabilities you're
gonna watch that content anyway okay so
the hope is that we're gonna give you
somewhat specific content because I'm
gonna give you content that's often
watched together but I'm gonna account
for the fact that you may be pointing
someone to popular content and you can
sort of make a hello world chart of what
that might look like so suppose that in
this super super normal that I and J are
seen together but probably is you're
gonna see J is quite high then this will
be
rating score that comes out but suppose
that I and J together is less likely but
probability of watching J in the first
place is super low then this is relevant
to actually start recommending and I
hope it's very clear this is a very
intuitive probabilistic argument but if
this is in production I can write this
in sequel in fact if this was a
streaming algorithm this is just
counting and it's so simple okay if you
grant a sequel that's what I said then
you can calculate very easily also you
can write tests for it if one of these
numbers ever higher than zero or lower
than one something goes wrong so you can
actually write some decent unit tests
for this and all parts of the algorithm
actually very interpret one you can even
turn into a personal recommender namely
take all the recommendations of all the
items a user saw multiply these scores
and boom you now have a personal
recommender as well so you know it's
kind of weird if people are considering
maybe starting with deep learning for
recommenders into some very cool work
being done in that space I definitely
not deny that but you're starting out
with this probably you need to think
about these sorts of things more and
suppose are we working at this
theoretical company doing actual
recommendations isn't even simple
algorithm that we can do we can we'll
just recommend the next episode and I'd
be very awkward at this particular video
service that as a potential client of
mine never tried recommending to the
next episode first if this is something
they didn't consider that's kind of
weird and if they never really
implemented a a testing or a random
testing just to test their baselines
I've also decided kind of suspicious and
if they were using about thinking about
using deep learning instead I don't know
then they're not probably not thinking
beyond the notebook and the hype around
these algorithms actually can be super
duper dangerous so I'll show you two
more examples to sort of show you those
sort of lure you back into the the
domain of simple models and you guys are
being a good crowd I've already done 100
slides with you today already so this is
going well one example is about video
games and the other example is about
chickens so let's pretend that we're
super Enterprise business model we have
a video game surface and people are in a
queue the problem with the situation is
that whenever people are in the queue
and they want to play a video game they
probably want to play a video game
against some of the same skill it's
super sucks if you're super good and
you're playing against a total newb it
also super sucks if you're told
getting his ass whooped so we need
somebody to SME player skill and that's
in this case assume that we have a
stream that comes in that can only say
this person that person this person won
that's the only thing we can actually
learn from we don't know anything happen
in the side of the match
I hope it's also very clear that if this
service is going to help people then we
probably don't want to wait for a batch
algorithm after every single game we
want the state to update and we want
something simple so this has a simple
insight first thing I would the first
way I would start thinking about this if
you have been playing this game for
years then I should be able to say your
skill estimation is much more precise
than someone who just came in and never
played a single game before so if we're
going to represent skill instead of
having a representation be a single
number it might be a good idea to say
hey skill is actually a belief I have a
belief of your skill I don't know
exactly what it is but it's a belief
okay simple way to model this follow
along I've got the distribution for
player 1 I've got a distribution for
player 2 then I also got because in
before the game has been played they're
independent of each other then I will
have to distribution of these two
players suppose that one of the two
players won you know I can just throw
away all the probability mass on one
side just draw a diagonal if player one
was the winner then probably all the
probability density matter was here has
just been declared unlikely because the
player lost the only thing I got to do
then is come up with a clever update
rule that sort of
translate this back into sort of
marginals for every single player but
one thing that's kind of nice to note is
I typically also have like a margin
around the diagonal which also means
that I can support draw gains if two
players are equal that also means that
their likelihood should be equal you can
then make a small simulation the proof
that this idea works so these are two
distributions killed when two people get
in one of the two wins you actually see
the one gets nudge to the right the
other one gets much to the left and vice
versa you can just simulate this to
convince yourself that it works and what
you can also do is you can simulate what
happens if one player is proven better
than the other player if these two will
battle it out the cool thing is if the
poor player won from the good one
there's going to be a huge shift in
belief if someone who was supposed to be
poor winning from someone who's supposed
to be super good and obviously there'll
be a much bigger change than when two
people who are supposed to be bad and
one wins from each other it makes sense
it's sort of information theory
basically at its best
also if the good player wins from the
bad player there's hardly anything is
updating so I get
of common sense for free still I would
like to know this worse so then you have
to find a data set the proof that this
works so I went for pokemons what you
can do is you can go to the poker API
get all the data from all the Pokemon
you can go to fan websites you get a
formula that tells you how one Pokemon
might beat another you can actually
simulate Pokemon games and after running
this I know so this is usually the point
in time we never want to get started so
just like the the small bit of energy
that I give you so that you understand
the final point of my talk anyway before
this gets meta these are all the
posteriors that you get if you run this
and basically we have a original belief
we updated after we see a single game
that believe is then held on that
another game gets played we updated
belief again and my conclusion is that
magikarp is the worst Pokemon so I think
it's safe to say that my algorithm works
Mewtwo is also in the top five so then
take your lead in designing this
algorithm was a whole lot simpler when I
considered I don't have to find some
sort of algorithm that fits my data set
no ignore all algorithms just think
about it myself
what makes sense to me how would I model
this with just common sense and it's
mainly the observation that I want to
use distributions instead of just a
single number for your skill that made
designing this easy but I really like
the algorithmic freedom I'm giving
myself got it five minutes this in
particular really fits the bayesian
mindset well and so it's something that
is worth mentioning because this is a
streaming algorithm as well and the way
that you can sort of see this the
distribution of the belief is all
massively if you think this is boring
sleep for like 10 seconds but the the
belief that I have after seeing three
data points is my prior that's sort of a
new person comes in times some sort of
update we're seeing the first data point
the second one the third one Hey look
the system is recursive we can do
streaming this is a very general thing
we have a nice little system that we can
define and in layman's terms if you come
up with a sensible update rule for
whatever we know before we see a data
point if you just come up with a update
rule that updates probability you're
done and it's lovely oh and if you do
the math you can also do these four
teams there's a separate talk I did at
Berlin buzzwords look at that if you
want to know how to do this for here's
to the storms the thing in this is and I
hope it's clear the model I've created
is just the history
but look at all the benefits we now have
we can quantify the uncertainty we can
apply the model in a streaming setting
and it's very easy to deploy understand
the bug in tests because we understand
every single step here and if you want
to come up with such a model the my best
advice would be take a step back from
the hype and sort of just you know have
a beer pen and paper sit on the thoracic
bed and just think about how you would
prefer to solve the problem if you were
not constrained by the machine learning
tools that we have we're blessed by them
I know this but you're also cursed in
the way let's talk about chickens as a
conclusion and I think I won't be
running too much out of time this is my
paper data set whenever I give trainings
I always say something about the chick
weight data set the idea is there's a
diet and there's a certain chicken that
belongs to that diet and at this point
in time this chicken was on this diet
and it weighed this much and we can make
a plot of it and this is a there's also
one of those data set that makes me a
proud vegetarian the idea here is
there's a farmer who tries to get the
chickens as fat as possible in 21 weeks
and it is sort of an a/b test on
different diets so what some people
might do that if you if you were to do
this in our they would say oh you know
what I'll just what Hutton code to diet
parameter and I'll put in the time I'll
just make some sort of linear model and
then there's a dummy variable for all
the diets this models wrong and I hope
you all agree because if I'm a point
zero here all the weights are almost the
same if a times zero all the diets are
about the same but the model that I just
proposed suggests that there's some sort
of constant I have to add depending on
the diet that you're in the sense this
makes no sense all wrong all wrong now
because I live in I also like to do
things in our in our there's a very cool
trick you can have a data frame inside
of a data frame so what you can do is
you say group by diet nest it then you
have a data frame within a data frame
and then you can run the machine
learning model per data frame so the
idea is per diet I'm not going to run a
separate linear regression which is
already much much better but it's still
wrong at least we're going to get
separate slopes and but it's not
possible of the intercepts not the same
and you know I've got a bit of prior
knowledge a chick has been born they
also have the about the same way they're
coming from the same distribution
any model that does this differently is
wrong so the conclusion then kind of is
I just want to grab a piece of paper
write down this formula and say this is
how I believe the world works the
Wake is modeled by having some sort of
constant for all the chickens and some
sort of interest sort of slope not
intercept some sort of slope that's
different for every chicken that's based
on the time and the only thing I want is
the computer to look at this and maybe
have some sort of domain-specific model
and it just it just I just wanted to run
in our there's a cool DSL called
rethinking and there's a function there
called map to Stan and it's kind of like
PI mc3 it's also kind of whatever tries
to do and the cool thing here is I can
actually sort of have a domain-specific
model we're kind of the features get
generated but also kind of the model
gets defined what I'm doing here is I'm
saying look there's some sort of
distribution that defines the weight
it's a Pentagon view which is some sort
of intercept times some sort of slope
times diet the slope is different per
diet and this engine is clever enough to
notice hey everything that's defined
that's null in this data frame that's
something I have to estimate and you run
this it compiles down to Sam and I'm
running over time just hang on for a
moment there's a break afterwards right
I'm almost there trust me
and this will get trained and because
this is a full Bayesian framework to get
some nice benefits namely what you get
is you get some uncertainty around the
parameters that you estimate which is
also kind of cool but I can go a step
further because if I look at this data
set I will see the variance increases
over time so I probably want to model
that as well okay make a new thing on my
the back of my envelope and then I add a
couple of expert parameters to this one
function and lo and behold it trains all
of this and the nice thing is in this
particular case I can actually inspect
the model I could confirm that this
works way better but I'm actually
dealing with uncertainty here as well so
I can actually sort of say hey the diet
for the beta parameter for diet three
that's super high oh and die three has a
much lower variance than the other one
so diet three is probably the best a
neural network usually doesn't have
allow me to do inspection of models as
detailed as what I've just shown you and
something very precious happening here
instead of modeling within the feature
space we can also keep models simple by
modeling in the model space all sort of
features that are automatically
generated by this DSL make it creative
modeling somewhat convenient and it's
the thing I really like and you can do
this for house prices you can do this
for diseases that have certain symptoms
but I'm running out of time
so let's do conclusion time instead I
hope that we life somehow inspired you
or at least convinced you that these
simple
there's still a worthwhile pursuit
future engineering can definitely still
save the day and it makes sense to come
up with systems instead of just simple
algorithms instead of mere algorithms
simple algorithms are cool simple
algorithms have properties that complex
algorithms are simply missing out on and
we should care about more than just ever
in the test set if you want to provide a
service I hope I've given a glimpse of
all the other things that you could be
looking at that are actually highly
beneficial and especially the case of
the recommender would you rather have a
recommended that's 1% better or
recommended as maybe 1% worse look an
update for every single mouse click or
the user sees you may be optimizing the
wrong thing here simple models can
actually be very advanced in smart
complex models can actually be
inarticulate and dumb fortunately they
seem to be unfortunetely as a fear of
missing out in this a dangerous pursuit
but let's start celebrating the fact
that we can still get simple models to
production simple models are easier to
explain understand debug maintain so
let's use them to solve problems
I definitely ran out of time but this is
145 slides so we did well yeah great
so the here's the awkward thing I am
between you guys and beer so if you want
to have questions we could do them now
but if oh wait no one awkward there's a
Keith weights no Holden's gave an
amazing talk afters I'm not between beer
but we should root but yeah we're and
also we have to make this space because
Holden's going to give an amazing
keynote a bit because the walls have to
be removing stuff right or do you have
time for questions
oh we're five minutes type of questions
yes Vincent
yeah thanks for a great talk oh yeah
over here the response I usually get you
know when I make this pitch is like
about scalability what what pitch you
know that idea that linear models should
be used over you know deep learning and
then they say oh okay well the feature
engine thing is really great and you
showed me a really cool example but what
if I have like a huge number of features
and I don't have time to do all of this
feature engineering I don't have the
resources
so part so features name can be partly
automated right and feature engineering
is another convex solve problem so
you're not going to do it perfectly
anyway and if you just try a couple of
simple ways to do feature engineering
automatically you can still manage a lot
of things I think and again the examples
that I showed you we're sort of obvious
things where there's a main knowledge
available to actually get the thing done
the way you want it but there are of
course still situations where it might
make sense to go a different route
that's fine but consider the simple
thing first don't do the complicated
thing before you've benchmarked a very
simple thing which includes recommending
the next episode for example Thanks
the argument against linear models is
not so much XOR but the typical argument
is outliers
especially when linear models are used
with somewhat naive error metrics sure
that's not a question but over spite
anyway the response not required so when
you're working with linear models what's
your favorite way of dealing with noisy
messy outlying data sure my favorite way
and this is only if I've got time for it
and again there's this notion of there's
a panda this model that I have to take
very careful for because with this one
model is super important to everything
and there's also these situations where
I just had one a thousand models that
are all-time series and I have to care
less per model but one thing I like to
do but it's also because when it helps
me to understand the data this is an
example where I have also defined how
noise works so I'm actually saying here
look the the noise is going to increase
over time and also how that noise is
increasing for that I've got uncertainty
bounds that are coming out of my model
so if preferably I prefer to do
domain-specific modeling and this is
cheap by the way usually you go to a
retail client you just have a coffee
with I know truck drivers someone who's
actually doing the work on the floor and
typically they will just tell you how to
do this they're not necessarily by
saying old outliers and Sigma know they
delete Lu how this works but but then on
your side you can deal with the
uncertainty however you want you just
have to model it appropriately that's
and that's still the art it's not soft
problem but you can manage kind of
another question yeah so up to now
you've been showing us how to basically
do feature engineering as a support
vector machine would be doing it are
there any other ways that you would
recommend
okay so so just just just to translate
I'm not saying that all complex models
are evil and should be put in the
dungeon right the main sort of the main
argument for starting with simple models
is if nothing else see it as a benchmark
and that the simplest example for
classification would be take the most
frequent class and especially when
you're doing things with recommendations
the thing that I that noise means so
much is the thing that people never do
when you do your first a be test do an a
a test that way you can test if you're a
beat splitting works because you don't
want to be making decisions for five
years and then realize oh none of them
mattered and the next thing you should
always do is doing a random test why
random because it's the worst possible
recommendation ever just do random stuff
from all of your content but you will at
least measure how many will people will
click anyway knowing this and then
realizing oh my recommend there's only
0.1% better than that means you haven't
figured out how recommender should work
on your platform if nothing else starts
simple this way and the main reason for
it is because otherwise you don't know
what's happening there's one more
yeah it's not like specific to the
linear model versus deep model thing but
more about streaming so how do you
account for the fact that as data comes
in you might be overfitting point or
like history bias or like super big one
so so the whenever something goes to
production
someone has to just give me a reason why
it's a good idea and some people might
also say hey doing it this way is not a
good idea but just as a general
architecture for this specific case I
could argue we can still do the batch
thing run that every night and just what
happens during the day we're going to do
in a streaming fashion and then I can
already limit some of the things that go
wrong because probably the world's not
changing overnight every single day
another thing that you can do if you're
worried that you're maybe overfitting a
bit and in the example that I gave on a
passive-aggressive there is this maximum
step size and you can specify it so
there are some sort of tricks that you
can deal with this in this particular
case though the main thing that I would
do is start monitoring this because
everyone can sort of do hand wavy
arguments that hey this could happen
that could happen I'm sure everything
can go wrong but maybe start measuring
it first and then still getting it live
first making sure the whole pipeline
works that's a good investment either
way so your concern is definitely valid
but measure it first then optimize but
there are very valid concern holds for
deep learning too
any more questions okay okay in that
case there's still tickets for pi day
time salon where we're looking forward
to serving everyone's through bubbles
thanks for listening and if you can all
do me a thing we all hate recruiters on
LinkedIn right so what you can do to
sort of annoy them a bit this is my
actual LinkedIn profile what you can
sort of do just for fun is you can list
all the Big Data technologies that
you're using and just chuck and just
chug in a few Pokemon names and [ __ ] and
just ask the recruiters if they can
understand which these things are
Pokemon and which aren't if we if we
just all promise to do this right now
LinkedIn will be a much better place
thank you